- What's up Believe Nation?
Today, I'm going to talk about
the seven lifestyle changes
that you need to adopt to be a success.
And as always guys, if you hear a point
that really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the comments below,
put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well,
and also writing it down
helps you lock it in for yourself too.
Enjoy.
So I've been asking entrepreneurs
what are the habits that you need
to have to be a success?
What do you see in morning routines
and what do you see in lifestyle
changes that people make
to go from having a job
to becoming a successful entrepreneur
and taking an idea that you have
and making something amazing?
What are the changes you
need to make in your life
to really get there?
And so today I'm going to share with you
my seven lifestyle changes that I think
every entrepreneur needs to
make to become a success.
Number one is establish a
morning routine for success.
I think this is so critical, so important.
Most people wake up, and their
life just explodes on them.
They have a morning routine,
but it wasn't designed with purpose.
It's wake up, go to the
washroom, grab a cup of coffee,
breakfast, and rush out.
It's not designed with
intent and with purpose.
I think what happens far too often
is entrepreneurs get inspired by something
at random points in
time, and then they have
these moments of boldness where they want
to create something amazing,
and then they wake up
the next day and it's over.
They're back to their baseline again.
They fall back down to earth.
They think about all those
limiting person beliefs,
and they say that big bold
idea that I had yesterday,
I can't do that, that's too crazy,
what was I thinking,
that was really stupid,
who am I to do that?
You're falling back down.
You're living a limited
life all over again,
and it happens to you every single day.
And so whatever that thing
was that got you inspired,
motivated, thinking big,
resourceful, unstoppable ...
Instead of it happening
randomly once a week
or once a month or whenever it happens,
schedule it in within
intent, with purpose.
Put it into your morning routine
so that every day you
start with that thing
that gets you feeling big,
bold, brave, and unstoppable.
Put that into your morning routine
and then let it carry forward for you
for the rest of the day.
Lifestyle change number two is
create a better environment.
The environment that you're in matters.
The people that you're around matters.
The physical environment
that you're in matters.
The sounds that are happening matter.
And so when you're working
or when you're in work mode,
what are you listening to?
What sounds are coming out?
What's on your walls around you?
Are you in an environment
that makes you come alive,
that makes you want to think bigger?
When I'm at my office,
I have these posters
on the wall of people who inspire me
for different reasons.
Five different people who inspire me
for different messages
and different reasons.
I walk into there and I'm like this is it.
I got to do something big today.
And those five people
may mean nothing to you.
That's okay.
It means something to me.
It helps me believe more.
And so creating that physical
environment for yourself.
A lot of people will say
well I don't have the money
to have a private island,
because the private island
is going to be the thing
that makes me come alive.
You can have a picture
of a private island.
You can get the feeling
It doesn't have to cost a lot of money
to create an amazing
environment for yourself.
Think about the friends that
you're hanging around with.
Thinking about the videos that you watch
and the things that you consume.
Are you going on YouTube
and watching prank videos,
or are you going on YouTube
and watching videos like this
where you get to be motivated, inspired,
and learn something?
Having that built in so that
you have a great environment
that sets you up for success
and reinforces the success all the time.
It's hard when you're an entrepreneur
because we don't have a boss.
There's nobody saying why are
you on Facebook right now?
There's nobody's saying why
are you answering those Snaps
and on Instagram and just texting people?
Why are you not working?
That's what a boss would do.
We are our own boss.
And there's a great freedom in that.
There's an amazing freedom.
That's part of the reason
why maybe you wanted to start
your own business, but there's also a lack
of accountability, and so you
want to have an environment
that holds you accountable.
When I'm working, and I
look up and I see Steve Jobs
looking back at me, it's
like get back to work Evan,
keep working, hustle, hustle harder, go.
When I'm watching videos
and doing the research
for the videos on this channel,
it reinforces it, like all
these successful people
are telling me every day,
you got to work harder,
you got to push better,
you got to learn more.
It just inspires me to want to
keep doing my absolute best,
and they hold me accountable.
My environment holds me accountable
because I don't have
a boss in my business.
So you have to create an environment
that is designed for your success.
Lifestyle change number three to adopt
is you need to accept responsibility.
Stop complaining and start
accepting responsibility.
A lot of people use excuses
for why their business
is not successful, right?
The economy's in the tank.
We have the new president.
Interest rates are up or
interest rates are down.
Or there's a war, whatever.
There's always an excuse.
There's always a reason why.
And as long as you can
blame somebody else,
you are never going to do anything.
As long as you can put
the blame over here,
it's the president's fault
that I'm not more successful,
that means you don't have to do anything,
because you gave up the responsibility.
It's their fault.
Successful entrepreneurs,
successful people,
accept the responsibility.
If you lost a customer, it's your fault.
If you're not more
successful, it's your fault.
Always accept responsibility
in every situation.
Your relationship isn't
where you want to go?
It's not your partner's fault,
it's your fault, fix it, now.
Sure, are other people involved?
Yes, but blaming them
doesn't fix anything.
So accepting responsibility
in every situation,
understanding how do I
fix this, what can I do?
Because I can't control everything else.
I'm not controlling interest rates.
I'm not controlling the economy.
I control what I do every day.
So let's fix that.
If you're not where you
want to be, it's your fault.
Accept that, and start
making some changes.
It sucks, because it's depressing,
because it's so easy to
have somebody to blame,
but it's also empowering because you know
that if you start making some changes,
you can start seeing big
things happen for you.
A lot of the best opportunities
come from complaints.
Where other people are complaining
that something is a certain way,
successful entrepreneurs turn
that into an opportunity.
The fact that people are complaining
means there's a pain.
Take that pain and solve it.
Here's a business for you.
And what's what successful people do.
They don't complain.
They don't wine.
They don't just talk to their friends
and say how bad everything is.
They accept responsibility,
they take action,
and they turn those pain
points into opportunities.
Lifestyle change number four
is you need to take action.
Take action.
Successful people take action.
Too many people just want to be a success.
They get off just thinking
about ideas, right?
Here's another idea.
Oh it'd be great if I could do this.
Or hey, here's what I would
do if I owned McDonalds.
That's great, but nothing's
ever going to happen for you
until you take action.
Thinking alone is not enough.
Thinking alone is only
part of the equation.
You got to do something about it.
And what happens a lot if you get an idea.
This happens to a lot of people.
You get some idea, and you have your job.
But you don't do anything about that idea.
You just have some job,
you keep going on it
because you say all these
reasons why you can't
do this business, and so
you're working on this job,
and then somebody else
goes off and makes millions
of dollars and has a
huge impact on the world,
off of that idea.
You say, that was my idea.
No it wasn't.
That was their idea too.
The only difference is they
did something about it.
So don't be upset at them.
Be upset at yourself.
It's nobody's fault.
Take responsibility.
Nobody else's fault but your own.
You have to do something.
Having the idea is not enough.
Have a big vision, it's
amazing, it's great,
I want you to have that big vision,
take an action step, small.
Think big, act small,
consistently, every day.
Go, do something.
Successful people take action.
And so the next time you get an idea,
just find some small way
to start, test it out.
You may think, hey, it could
be a new lifestyle thing too.
Hey, I want to take salsa classes.
Instead of dreaming for years
about taking salsa classes,
go out and take a salsa class.
You may hate it.
I don't think you'll hate it
if you take it at (mumbles) Salsa,
but you may hate it, and
at least now you know.
You don't have to spend
the rest of your life
wondering and worrying about it.
Or you may take it and love it.
And then you adjust and find other ways
to get involved in it
and continue dancing.
Maybe it becomes a business for you.
When you get an idea about something,
find a small way to get
started immediately.
Stop waiting, stop delaying.
Take action.
Now you can't do everything
yourself in your business,
and you're likely doing things
that you shouldn't be doing.
If you're doing something important,
you have to build a team.
The first person I hired
was for one hour a day,
and he freed up more than
an hour of my time a day
because he was better
at the work than I was,
and then I slowly built up my team.
And so you can hire somebody.
You may not have enough
money to have somebody
come on full time on your business,
but to hire somebody for an hour a day
or a couple hours a week, to help take off
some of the tasks that
you shouldn't be doing,
will really help.
You want to spend as much time
in the CEO role as possible.
That's where you want to be.
And so looking at your schedule
and seeing where am I spending time
that should be eliminated?
What things can be automated?
And then whatever's left
that still has to get done,
how do I delegate some
of these other things
so that I can focus on what I'm great at.
So when I started my YouTube channel,
I did everything myself.
I'm a big advocate of not spending money
until you're making money.
No point in hiring somebody
if you're making zero on your business,
but as soon as I started making money
on my YouTube channel,
I was doing everything.
I was the cameraman, I was the
editor, I was the researcher,
I was in front of the camera, everything.
As soon as I started making some money
on my YouTube channel, it put it back in,
and the first person
I hired was an editor.
Because editing took me a long time,
I wasn't very good at it,
I didn't want to get good
at it, more importantly,
and then as I started making more,
I hired more people, more
editors, a cameraman,
I bought more gear, I got
cameras, I got microphones,
I got researchers, I got people to help me
on the YouTube channel with the comments,
and so my team grew as my business grew,
but the thing that really helped skyrocket
the early growth was
getting my first editor.
So as soon as you can afford it,
bringing somebody on to help
alleviate some of the tasks
that you're not good at,
and more importantly,
don't want to get good at either,
can really help you quickly
scale up your business
and reduce the stress because
you get most stressed out
when you're doing work
that you don't want to do.
The number six lifestyle
change you need to make
to be successful is you
need to be consistent.
So many people are not consistent.
So many entrepreneurs I talk to have a day
where they're on fire
and doing so much work
and building up and sending
emails and marketing
and pouring their love
into product development
and then nothing, the next day nothing,
the next day nothing,
and it just falls apart,
until like next week or next month.
Another great day, super productive.
You have to understand.
It takes time for momentum to build.
You will not have success by
just having these short spurts
with long gaps in between.
It's far better to spend
half an hour to an hour
every single day on your business
than one day a week all in on the company.
Because momentum takes time to build up.
If you look at anybody whose
had success in any field.
Not just entrepreneurship, in any field.
It's not just working.
It's not just taking action.
It's taking action
consistently, every single day.
Put it in your calendar and
sticking by the calendar.
Doing the work consistently
is what separates the high
achievers from everybody else.
And there's always an excuse
for why you can't do it.
I get it, there's always
some kind of excuse.
There's a wedding to go to.
There's an illness in the family.
There's legit reasons.
And there's others that are not legit
that are just based off of your fear.
You can always find a reason
why you shouldn't do something, always.
And if you look at the most
successful people in the world,
they had more reasons than
you do for not doing anything.
Look at how they started.
Look at where they came form.
Most of these people ...
I'm not talking about inherited wealth.
I'm talking about people who
built something for themselves.
Look at where they came from.
They had less than what
you already have right now.
They had every excuse in the world
not to take action consistently.
Every reason in the world
why they had to go off
and do something else instead,
and they found the time, somehow,
to focus on building this thing
that they said was important
to them and they did it.
Meanwhile, you're sitting on your excuses
and your reasons for why you can't do it.
Stop the excuses.
Consistent daily massive action.
Habit number seven is you
have to believe in yourself.
I think of all the ones
we've talked about today,
none of them matter if you
don't believe in yourself.
You can take lots of action,
but if you don't believe in
the work that you're doing
and believe that you can make it happen,
it's not going to happen.
What you believe you can do, you will do.
If you believe that you can, you can.
If you believe that you
can't, then you can't.
So I think one of the most
important things that you can do
is learn how to develop that
inner belief in yourself.
I got it a lot through my parents
who told me I was Evan
Castrilli Carmichael
and could do anything that I wanted.
I continue that tradition off to my son
where every time I drop him off at school
or say good night,
it's either Carmichaels can do anything
or I am Haden Carmichael
and I can do anything,
to give him the confidence in himself,
but if you don't get that your parents,
you don't get that from your friends,
it's fine, get them from videos,
get them from books,
get them from resources,
get them from circles around you.
I got more of my confidence now ongoing
through the videos that I put up.
I'm surrounding by
successful people daily.
Not in person, but through my videos.
Every day I'm surrounded by Elon Musk.
and Steve Jobs and Howard Schultz
and all these people
feeding knowledge and wisdom
and motivation into me,
making me a better leader,
making me more confident.
Making me believe in what
I'm doing and in myself more.
If you want the change the world,
then you have to believe that
you can change the world.
You can say it all you want,
but if you don't believe it,
nothing's going to happen.
And so building that self confidence up.
Creating that environment
and that morning routine
and those rituals, where
if you find the things,
if this channel makes you
believe in yourself more,
then watch the channel more.
If my channel doesn't
do that, unsubscribe,
go somewhere else, but do something.
Because that inner belief is critical.
Successful people believe in themselves.
Successful people believe
in the vision that they have
when nobody else believe in it.
They have this big vision for
what they want to accomplish,
and everybody thinks they're crazy.
It doesn't matter.
I'm still going to go out and do it.
You need to have that unshakable belief
in yourself, in the
project, in the mission,
if you want to go out sand
make something big happen.
So that's my take on the
seven lifestyle changes
that you need to make in
order to be a success.
I'd love to know what did you guys think.
Which one was your favorite and why.
Did I miss an eight, nine, 10,
that you guys want to add to the list?
Put it down in the comments below.
Super curious to hear
what you have to say.
I also want to give a big
shout out to Katie Kruse.
Katie, thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word, and
for making that awesome video
on it as well.
I really really really
appreciate the support,
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.